nicolas vidal merci de nous avoir
rejoints sur l'antenne de la matinale de
rtl france alors quelle analyse vous
faites vous de la stratégie vaccinale
bonjour et meilleurs voeux à vous de en
tout cas c'est la facture très salée du
déclassement de la france depuis 30 ans
première chose déjà on a tous des dégâts
l'union européenne rappelez vous un
l'achat de vaccins que les négociations
de contrat un peu avant et puis
également la vaccination du vaccin alors
et au niveau national là aujourd'hui on
est dans le plan de vaccination version
tableau excel avec des chiffres des
dates des rigueurs objectif est bien
entendu le gouvernement s'affronte à la
virulence des critiques et des
inquiétudes légitimes
un exemple hervé morin hier qui déclare
chez nos confrères de sud radio et
wingles affirme être en discussion
l'humain avec un groupe pharmaceutique
pour acheter directement des deux c'est
d'ailleurs aussi la position je crois de
renaud muselier
donc là on est vraiment à quelque chose
on arrive au démembrement de l'état et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi très
rapidement et puis un point extrêmement
important
on est dans un système de recherche
totalement sinistré c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de vaccin
français en france aucunement validé
dans la nation de pasteur imaginez-vous
on les gens ne veulent pas de
paracétamol et d'autre mais là on a
totalement perdu notre souveraineté
sanitaire ça c'est le premier point
voilà et après il ya des choses qui me
semble extrêmement importante et on va
en parler ensemble sur le démembrement
de l'état
pourquoi la france selon vous est elle à
la traîne mais parce que manuel mâcon
est en train de découvrir finalement que
l'état nation cet état souverain est en
capacité de protéger les français
et là on s'affronte à quoi finalement on
est en train de s'affronter à un
l'apothéose déclassement de la france et
ça a été le fil rouge cette crise
sanitaire
rappelez-vous les masques les tests pcr
les îlots de l'isolation pour les
malades
ça c'est absolument absolument central
pour moi dans ce déclassement absolue
parce que finalement on a la france est
devenue a été démembré on a tout
privatiser regardez aujourd'hui l'appui
du cabinet américain mckinsey qui va
privatiser la stratégie vaccinale donc
aujourd'hui au gouvernement finalement
qui vont conseiller mais la réalité
c'est que ces gens vont appuyer l'état
pour adopter une stratégie importante
donc ça veut dire que l'état est
totalement des membres et les tabacs
plus d'un fracture n'a plus de logique
et il vous reste au mieux de ce grand
champ de ruines qu'est la france
bureaucratie qui est totalement dépassée
avec sa lourdeur administrative
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur le point
il ya quelque chose qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est les masques le stock
des masses comme menacés l'émergence ce
problème du démembrement de la france je
lisais ce matin avec beaucoup
d'impatience ce rapport du sénat de
décembre 2001 qui pointe les
incohérences et il a faibli de la
stratégie j'oublie par exemple le stock
des matelas ffp2 je lis de 2011 à 2016
de stocks stratégiques des masques ffp2
est passé de 700 millions d'unités à 700
milles soit une diminution de 99%
ça c'est absolument central parce que ça
veut dire que l'état depuis 30 avec une
politique néolibérale d'austérité de
réduction des coûts est allé faire des
économies de bouts de chandelle et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après eh bien
l'état bien entendu avec le problème de
stocks stratégiques est allé mettre des
dizaines de milliards d'euros pour
soutenir l'économie ou du mot de prendre
à perfuser donc on essaie de mégoter des
dizaines de millions d'euros une
centaine millions d'euros se démasque
pour faire en stock stratégique derrière
qu'est-ce qui se passe eh bien l'état
est obligé de cracher au bassinet pour
tenter de sauver la france et son
économie
ce n'est que la perfusion parce que le
jour où on va tous les branchés cette
france va tomber dans un chômage de
masse un chômage endémique et ça va être
une catastrophe sociale donc finalement
on le voit très bien à un moment donné
les tasses et démembrée depuis trente
ans et c'est pâques emmanuel macron à sa
date depuis un certain temps et
aujourd'hui on privatise même la
situation sanitaire la stratégie
sanitaire comme intention de privatiser
les retraites et que qu'une série de
choses donc qui manuel macron il se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans une impasse
oui c'est même lui et demi dans cette
stratégie délibérée a finalement vous
savez bossuet disais il se plaindre des
conséquences dont ils chérissent les
causes et emmanuel macron aujourd'hui il
peut taper du poing sur la table
millet au site l'acteur de la start up
nation qui finalement ressemble plus à
un hôpital de campagne où on finira par
distribuer les vaccins avec amazon prime
dans quelques semaines nicolas il vous
reste quelques secondes
en quelques mots la vaccination
obligatoire pourrait-elle voir le jour
ah bin là vous savez emmanuel parfois on
nous a dit que je serais pas le but mais
finalement ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va nous dire que
n'y aura pas de vaccination obligatoire
je sais que jean marc silvert parler du
permis de conduire mais à un moment
donné il ya des choses qu'on pourra pas
faire prendre un avion aller au
restaurant établissements culturels
donc ça va proposer vraiment un problème
de liberté publique de liberté
individuelle cette vaccination
et vous savez qu'aujourd'hui il ya
encore une majorité de français et le
chiffre ne cesse d'augmenter qui aurait
sans sont opposés à la vaccination
donc ça c'est être aussi un grand enjeu
des prochaines semaines mais finalement
comme l'état n'est pas en capacité n'est
plus en capacité de répondre et ne fait
que la communication autour du virus
parce qu'il est qu un membre des membres
et ça posera un énorme problème de
politique de philosophie politique et de
philosophie à l'échelle tir de
philosophie démocratique
merci beaucoup c'est le grand mot
aujourd'hui democracia on l'a vu avec
les états unis merci nicolas vidal et et
bonne année à vous bien sûr à jeudi
prochain